all right welcome everyone to graduating
bits uh
where we have a very full schedule so
we're just going to jump right into it
uh we have 17 awesome people
who are on the job market this year and
uh first off we're gonna be starting
with rpgs who's currently at oculus and
on the interestingly the phd program uh
job market go ahead up youtube
hello everyone i'm abhijit and i'll be
talking about uh
myself uh and uh like any good talking i
start to explain the title so
this is how you pronounce my name uh
it's
is my mother tongue it's a language from
south india it's a spot like this
uh and yeah as galton mentioned i'm uh
i'll find a phd prayer of this cycle
and i didn't realize that this was
mostly for
uh people on the real job market but
nonetheless uh
here i am uh my research interests are
uh
mostly in theoretical computer science
uh unsurprisingly i interested in
all things quantum pcb games analytic
methods in tcs
and uh fine grained algorithms and
complexity and uh i also done some
number theory and i'm especially
interested in analytic memory theory
arithmetic statistics and automorphic
forms
uh after what i've actually done uh i
just in the previous session
uh talked about uh laura bound that
worked on with
ryan williams at mit and that's on
linear time quantum
np against small space and in particular
the theorem is that
linear time quantum classical merlin
earthquake ram can't be
uh simulated by a small space of n to
the c
time rams for c less than about 2.366
we also showed some wire bounds against
small space randomized machines in this
work
uh so on linear time m a on a ram and on
linear time q say manicure i'm against
problem
histograms uh in number theory uh i
won't
detail this theorem but basically uh uh
with mentioned matchkey at boston
university
uh i worked on uh an asymptotic for how
many quadratic number fields have
some property that we care about the
lower bound is known already but we
got the upper bound and in fact the
precise asymptotic constant and there
are some other
independently interesting analytics
number three results in this picture
uh right now i'm an os engineer we're
looking at oculus
and uh in research i'm thinking about
quantum area correcting codes
summary groups in quadratic twist
families and i'm also trying to think
about arithmetic certain
lower bounds and using the techniques
that combine num ray theory and
complexity theory uh yeah i'm hoping to
start a phd in mastercs and fall 21
uh and i finished my undergrad at mit uh
as a club remember the class of 2019
uh yeah i guess here are some photos of
me doing
opt-off so this is me seeing my college
appellate group i think this is the last
chord of the last piece of my last
concert
this is street food in hyderabad india
where i was born
and this is me in the salad
in bolivia where i went in 2019 don't
worry
uh for after graduation
uh cool thank you
awesome thank you uh next up is supratim
at iit
gandhinagar and uh he's on the job
market for post doc positions could you
please share a screen now please
perfect can see you uh go ahead let's
see your slides
whenever you're ready
ah sorry sorry it was i think i was mute
hi i am supratim from iit gandhinagar
india
i work on online courses for various
machine learning algorithms
supervised by professor anivandasgupta
so many of you might know what is core
set but
just for the sake let me just tell you
briefly so
corset is basically a small
representative of the data
such that if you run any learning method
on this code set then the result you
would get
is more or less the same if you run the
algorithm on the entire data
so so here in our case the core site is
nothing but
a weighted sub sample of the data
so uh here is a um here is a
small glimpse of the research that we
have done in this area
so um so for the case of tensor
factorization
and lp subspace embedding we give
various online algorithms that creates
course sets
such that the guarantees of these code
sets beats
they are state of the art results
in terms of sampling size
working space and handwriting time we
presented this paper in icm last year
we also presented one more paper uh
where we talk about core sets for for
regularized recreation
but basically um when you apply
a regularizer on a on a regression what
you expect is that
the corset size foot would reduce but uh
here we show that it is impossible to
get a
core set size um i mean a smaller corset
size for a
lasso problem compared to the corset
size of a least square equation
in case of a clustering problem um we
have
shown online algorithms to create core
sets for
clustering based on bregman divergences
for the same problem we also give core
sets
whose which is non-parametric in nature
as in the size of the course that is
independent of
the dimension of your input point as
well as
k the number of clusters you are
expecting
in the data so um so
yeah so in here our algorithms are
online in the nature because for
every incoming point uh our sampling
decisions are taken
without looking at the next input point
so yeah
um here's i mean and uh these are couple
like i said uh we have to stop after
three minutes
uh the next one will be uh gopinath
mishra
yes so
can you also see my slides yep this is
fine
hi everyone this is i am a graduate
student
at the indian statistical institute
broadly my research is in randomized
algorithms with
uh i can't hear you anymore
i don't know i don't care either
uh copy nuts can you say something hello
yeah yeah okay
if you're fine yes uh can you hear me
okay
oh sorry uh
okay so my work on sublinear time
algorithm or query complexity
is on both local and global query models
for graphs
in local query models where we get some
local information through each query
i worked on two problems first it is
about query complexity of global minimum
cut
in general graph model second uh
tolerant graphite summarizing problem in
dense graph models
apart from local query as i have
mentioned i also worked on
global query where we get some global
information
via each each query so using global
query
uh query we have studied uh triangle
counting
hyper accounting and parameterized
heating set in the uniform hypergraph
problem
i also did uh these three works
in sublinear space that is streaming
algorithm first one in this in this
slide is about
about the streaming streaming complexity
of some basic geometric problem
the second one is about study of the
graph coloring problem a variant of
black graph coloring problem
in vertex arrival stream where the graph
as well as the
coloring function on the vertices arrive
in a string
the third one in this slide is about
study of
subgraph deletion and minor relation
problem
in different graph streaming streaming
models
apart from work on sublinear time and
southern use space algorithm
i also are i did work in communication
complexity
we considered the classical steady
business problem where the players
get inputs from a known bounded
dc-dimension
set system and in this case we resolved
the
query complex communication complexity
up to lock factor
so this slide shows hype of my published
work
in the area of sublingual algorithm and
all these things are going to be part of
my thesis
apart from sublinear algorithm i got a
chance to work
a little on discrete mathematics and
metric embedding problem
where i i was fortunate to get this
this four publications apart from these
publications in somethinger
algorithms and uh discrete mathematics
metric embedding
i have also some unpublished work
currently
about uh which are either submitted are
going to be submitted
uh in the news near future
so now i would like to conclude my talk
by saying that
i am about to finish my phd in the near
future
and currently looking for a postdoctoral
position broadly in area of
randomized algorithm specifically i will
be fortunate if i get
some positive questions all right thank
you um can we continue with shaswatch
please
hi i'm just gonna share my screen
all right so i'm joshua i'm doing my i'm
finishing my phd at stanford my advisor
is mary wooters
and i'm moving to google in a couple of
months but
i'm very interested in you know staying
engaged with the theory community
and i thought i'd share like a small
aspect of
like my research with you guys so i work
on error correcting codes
but this talk is very short so i'm not
going to be able to tell you anything
about errors or their correction
but i can still explain some kinds of
problems i'm interested in so code
is just a subset of all strings over an
alphabet of
length uh all strings of length n over
an alphabet sigma
and the rate is kind of a proxy for its
size it's just the log of its size
divided by the block length
and in the stock we'll think of the
alphabet always as fq
so you can think of a code as just a
subset
over a high dimensional vector space
and i study the combinatorial properties
of error correcting codes
so if you study combinatorics you often
know that random objects are very ideal
properties
so we should study random ensembles of
codes to sort of get a sense of what is
possible with their correcting codes
so very natural thing to study is just a
completely random code which is you just
pick a subset
of a certain size completely random
in which every point is independently
chosen completely randomly of each other
or you can study slightly more
structured subsets which are
for example random subspaces
amongst all the subspaces of some given
co-dimension or you can
study even smaller subsets of random
subspaces which
like for example ldpc codes which it
doesn't really matter what they are but
you can think of all three of these
things as successive do randomizations
completely random codes are very random
random linear codes are random but less
so and
lgbc are further less random
so what kind of properties do i actually
care about these codes
these questions are very simple i might
ask questions like
how much does one of these codes from
these ensembles intersect with a hamming
ball
how much does it intersect in
you know with you know a combinatorial
rectangle
and can we really quantifiably
understand the differences between these
very simple
objects in these very simple ways so
what's really cool is when we think
about properties of
error correcting codes chosen from these
random ensembles
they often undergo phase transition by
what by that i mean that if you
look at a code of a certain rate or size
there is a and given a property the
probability that a random code of that
rate satisfies this probability is close
to zero until it immediately jumps to
one
beyond that rate so we call this a phase
transition
so in my research i'm able to show that
for very natural properties which are
very large classes of properties codes
like the properties undergo phase
transition and we can
actually really simply characterize the
rate at which these phase transitions
occur
how simple is this characterization well
simple enough for maybe a five minute
talk but maybe not a three minute doc
um and we get lots of cool results we
get results about you know fine grain
information about the geometry of these
high dimensional subsets and subspaces
and we show certain new results about
ldbc codes which
basically says that this
de-randomization doesn't lose anything
from completely random linear codes and
we open up some new
new avenues for constructing linear time
incredible and
decodable codes which achieved thank you
uh if we could proceed with jasper yep
can you hear me yeah just as a heads up
i think i'll start giving people a 30
second warning
go ahead yup i'm screen sharing right
now
there we go um hi everyone i'm jasper
lee i'm a final year student at brown
advised by paul valiant
i'm currently on the market for post
opposition and today i want to tell you
about my research interests
which uh focus on data efficiency of
algorithms
now because we only have three minutes
please excuse me that i'll be using my
fast
teaching voice for this so
i'm interested in both uh foundational
and classical problems as well as
problems in new models so let me
highlight two of my recent results
both with my advice i paul first we
resolve a fundamental problem in
statistics
namely how do we optimally estimate the
mean of a real value distribution
the standard solution is to just use the
empirical mean namely your sum of all
your samples and normalize it
and then we use tailbones to analyze it
the issue
with this kind of approach is that
different tail bounds actually give you
different convergences
and require you to make different kinds
of assumptions about the distribution
and in fact the convergences are all
sub-optimal
so we settle this problem by giving an
estimator with convergence that is not
only big o tight but we even get the
right constant
parameterized by the variance and
moreover our algorithm is
simple to describe and computable in
linear time and therefore is actually
applicable in practice
this work is currently in submission
with a draft on archive already
i'm really proud of this work and would
be very happy to talk
more about this offline so let me move
on to a
another result in a new model that is
inspired by crowd sourcing
where crowdsourcing has this really
crucial aspect that
the answers we get from the crowd are
typically unreliable and noisy
so the problem we're interested in is
given a database we want to use
crowdsourcing to estimate the amount of
wrong data in the database
for example what's highlighted in red
right here using the fewest
crowdsourcing tasks
um this problem can be theoretically
modeled as a
population of coins where we are trying
to estimate the fraction of coins with
positive bias
and we want to do this by flipping the
coins as few times as possible
one of the main challenges of working on
this project is that the algorithms in
this model can be really adaptive
so our result shows that uh give tight a
bigger tight bounce
we show a an optimal adaptive algorithm
also with experiments to back up its
performance
as well as a tight fully adaptive lower
bound
and we also show a separation between
the performance of adaptive and
non-adaptive algorithms for this problem
in this model
this paper is appearing in soda in fact
i'll be talking more about this on
sunday
so please feel free to come
let me end this by mentioning some of
the other works i've done
beyond statistical problems i'm also
interested in computational concerns
so at the beginning of my phd i've also
worked on
optimizing star convex functions so
start confess functions
are a family that really vastly
generalizes convex functions
and these functions can be really really
discontinuous and
even for these like very weird function
family we give a polytime algorithm for
optimizing them
recently with other co-authors i've also
worked on
approximating the maximum of gaussian
kernel density estimates
so i don't think i've run out of time
this is all i have
uh with with the time if you're
interested in the work i've done i'd
really love to talk to you
thank you thanks nicole
nicole are you there yep cool
okay hi everyone i'm nicole
i'm a final year phd student at mit my
advisor is virginia vasilevska williams
and i'm on the market for a postdoc so
in my research we consider very large
graphs
and what i mean by that is like if you
gave me an algorithm that runs in
polynomial time or even like cubic time
or quadratic time we could say you know
this is going to be too slow for this
very large graph and so
two themes of my research that fall
under this
idea are theme number one approximation
algorithms for problems in p
meaning that if you have a problem that
runs with an algorithm that runs in
let's say quadratic
time what we would like to be able to do
is to get an approximation algorithm
that runs much faster let's say in
linear time
another theme of my research is on
dynamic algorithms
so let's say your graph here is changing
over time and we would like to be able
to
update our solution in order to reflect
the changes in the graph
and again because the graph is so large
we don't have time to recompute the
whole solution from scratch
every time the graph changes and so we
would like to instead maintain a very
efficient data structure that allows us
to
update the solution so i'll talk about
one particular project
which falls under theme one here so
also i'm interested in both in upper
upper bounds and lower bounds
so the project that i'll talk about is
uh the diameter
problem so the diameter is just simply
the largest distance in the whole graph
so we're interested in getting an
algorithm that computes just the largest
distance in the whole graph
and it turns out that the best exact
algorithm that we know to do this
is just to run all pairs shortest paths
find all of the distances
take the largest one and output that one
and it's also known that you can't get a
significantly faster
algorithm than this under the strong
exponential time hypothesis
so that motivates the question of trying
to get even faster algorithms but were
allowed to settle for an approximation
so there have been many papers on this
topic and some of them even have been
there's been
a lot of work on this even just in the
last couple of months
so our goal here is to be able to output
a solution
that's almost the right length but not
quite the right the right length
so it turns out there are several
algorithms to do this you can get time
accuracy trade-off algorithms for
example
two approximation in linear time etc um
and my work on this project on this
problem with collaborators has been
mostly on
showing that in addition to getting a
time accuracy trade-off
algorithms you can also get time
accuracy trade off
conditional lower bounds and that's all
i have thanks a lot for listening
perfect thanks a lot nicole um next up
we have suhail
all right can you hear me yeah um are
you gonna share all right yeah i'm
sharing
a screen can you see it
yes all right so
uh i'm suhail sharif and i have
nearly completed my phd my thesis just
needs to be reviewed
and it's under arkadev chattawadie at
tifr in mumbai and this is my thesis
title as you can see it's
based on query complexity lower bounds
and it has applications in communication
complexity and quantum optimization
so i'm currently on the market uh for a
postdoc position
and i thought i would just say something
about my interests
so the stuff that i've worked until now
have mainly been in query complexity and
communication complexity and the most
seductive aspect of these
is their relation to algebraic measures
it's always nice to think about and
while thinking about this we had
i along with some co-authors notice that
the log approximate rank conductor is
false and
this is not just an elegant result but
it also
it has implications for stuff like
quantum versus randomized communication
complexity if you want a separation
between these two
then you need to really understand when
is it that communication complexity is
not uh exactly the measure of
approximate rank now
in the study of quantum versus
randomized communication complexity
xor functions play a huge role and
they're
not that well understood which is why we
also look at parity decision trees
randomized priority this entries are
also not very well understood
and there's just so many connections in
these areas that one can explore
just looking at parity decision trees
brings up combinatorial questions about
the hypercube and subspaces and
yeah so these are my interest is in all
of these related topics
uh further i'm interested in quantum
query complexity for the
insights that you can get with quantum
query algorithms
and in fact one of the papers that
one of the results that i have is going
to be presented tomorrow
here at itcs do check it out i won't
be presenting it because it's around 4
am for me
but my co-author robin kotari will be
presenting it
um yeah that's about it i'm also
interested in looking at
just general things in computational
complexity
anything that halting problems and
everything is quite elegant
communication complexity so i'm open for
anything in that
all right thank you for listening and
back to you
perfect thank you suhail next up is
peter dixon
hello hey you're good okay
uh i'm peter um i mostly work on
randomized algorithms from a
complexity perspective uh i'm currently
looking for
uh postdoc positions um
so what i've been working on lately is
pseudo-determinism
that's where you have a random algorithm
like it's still random
but it looks deterministic in the sense
that it can just
consistently outputs the same value like
if you think about a prime generating
algorithm this one will consistently
give you the same prime number
and so the main question is what can you
actually do pseudo-deterministically
so we had a neat connection to circuit
lower bounds where if you can do a stock
myers algorithm
pseudo-deterministically then you get
new circuit lower bounds for uh
zpp within the oracle and truth table
queries
not only that but we can get really
close to pseudo-deterministic we can get
it to output a
constant number of solutions like from a
constant size set pseudo
deterministically
and then my talk at this conference was
on a completeness concept for
pseudo-determinism
where if you can estimate collision
probability
uh pseudodeterministically that lets you
get a lot of pseudo-deterministic
algorithms in particular
anything with a constant number of
solutions you can make fully suited
deterministic
other stuff i've worked on uh i did some
computational complexity distribution
testing connections
so let's say you've got two sampleable
distributions you want to know if
they're similar
or uh not similar it's uh probably the
like the basic problem for distribution
testing
um so by studying this problem we were
able to show that
non-interactive perfect zero knowledge
is unconditionally contained in
uh sbp which is kind of like a
it's bpp but with a worse probability
um but you can't push that much farther
unless you can get some non-relativizing
results we were able to give
oracles separating uh the interactive
version
and you also can't get an ipzk in
cosvp and as a nice corollary this
gives you a relativized separation
between pzk and non-interactive pck
i've also done stuff with a multi-pass
randomness so normally if you're looking
at space bounded randomized computation
you look at the random string one way
like you only get to read it once you
can't remember it for free
um so what happens if we uh remove that
restriction
um and one reason for studying this
is that we showed that if you can
de-randomize
in polynomial time uh log space
multi-path seconds uh then you can get
an unconditional derandomization
a weak one but unconditional for
time-bounded classes
and we can de-randomize it in log space
but we need a non-uniform linear advice
uh yeah that's all i've got thank you
thanks a lot peter um next up is william
uh one sec
let's see
there we go go ahead okay uh hi everyone
i'm william hoza my advisor is david
zuckerman
i'm a phd student at the university of
texas at austin
and i'm looking to graduate this may and
after that i'm interested in a postdoc
position i'm on the market for postdoc
positions starting in the fall
i'm especially interested in
pseudo-randomness and de-randomization
uh my dream would be to prove l equals
bpl
unconditionally to de-randomize
space-bounded computation to show that
random bits are not necessary for
efficient space-efficient computation
this is a dream i share with plenty of
other researchers though
so let me just give you an idea of of uh
you know some things that i've done
failing that uh i i like to work on
pseudorandom generators
i like unconditional constructions of
pseudorandom generators so for example
uh
dean duron puya hatami and i uh
designed the first uh near-optimal
pseudorandom generators for
read once ac zero uh
pseudorandom generators i guess are are
like the most standard approach to
proving a deer randomization theorem
something like l equals bpl
um and i think they're also really
elegant you know mathematically i i
think they're really elegant
uh constructions i'm also interested in
like
less conventional approaches for deer
randomization
so for example hitting sets a hitting
set is a sort of a one-sided version of
a pseudorandom generator
and david zuckerman and i designed
hitting sets for rl
with optimal dependence on epsilon the
threshold parameter
um and then in a follow-up work uh quan
chang and i
uh proved that optimal hitting sets for
rl actually can be used you know in a
non-trivial way uh to de-randomize bpl
and so i think those two works kind of
go together
um so yeah i mean more generally i'm
interested in like creative
uh approaches to de-randomization um
i also i'm happy to work on problems
that aren't you know related to cedar
randomness and deer randomization
more generally i i like complexity
theory and the analysis of boolean
functions
um anything that has sort of
mathematically elegant techniques
and then well-motivated computational uh
interpretations i i i think is really
appealing
so that's all thanks for listening cool
thank you very much uh william
um next up is yi ding fung
yep go ahead are you ready
cool hello everyone this is iding from
i'm a fifth year phd student from
northwestern computer science
and my research interests including
metro design online algorithm and
machine learning
and i'm excited about the problem from
other areas like economics
and operation research and try to solve
them
from perspective of computer scientists
and i'm very fortunate to be advised by
jason harlan
so next let me give you some tests about
the problem interesting
so mechanical designs are area
originally from economics
but now it's become also popular in
computer science
and from a computer science perspective
i can design some kind of
multi-party computation where different
parts have their own data
for example here we want to allocate the
apple to one of the two agents
and different agents will have different
value for example and those value can be
solved as their own data
and in the multi-party competition so
there are two major concerns
first who should be doing which part of
the computation
and second how can we guarantee that
they will do it correctly
well in macro design people answer the
second question pretty well
specifically let's assume that the
player are rational
in this sense we can try to implement
some of the game theoretic and central
poison
however for the first question the
literature in system design
suggests that we should ask all the
party to do some
part of their computation because in
this way the final protocol will be both
simple
and robust on the other hand for the
macro design literature
people prefer that only the central
central mechanism should do the
computation in other words
most of the results in mechan design
will consider truthful mechanism
where other player will report their
true information
to the mechanism and the other
computation will be response
by the mac itself and
in the literature most results focus on
choosing mechanism because it's easy to
do the analysis however on the other
side
we have we have non-truthful mechanism
where all the players
need to compute their own strategy in
the equilibrium in other words they need
to respond for some of the computation
and and and usually those launches
making it hard to analyze
however in practice we know that
non-choice maps are pretty
popular for example google google ads
just switched their protocol
to the first price auction which is a
non-truthful mechanism
and therefore a natural question we can
ask here is that are there any
theoretical evidence that non-truthful
mechanism
are better than truthful mechanism
because if it is the case
it suggests that our community should
pay more attention
and spend more effort on this area
and the answer is yes so in a joint work
with
jason hardline and in kylie we show that
in a
in private bottom mechanical design
which is a standard framework in the
literature
there exists non-regulation there is no
trigger relation there
in other words the optimal announcements
for mechanism is strictly better than
the truthful making
and that's it thank you thank you you
ding
next up is vagos
nice thank you for organizing g
let me share my screen
all right you're good you can see my
screen right
yes perfect hi everyone
thanks for tuning in i'm vagus
i graduated from stanford last summer
and now i'm a postdoc in google new york
and i won't tell you a little bit about
my work
the first thing i won't tell you is that
data
contain higher hierarchies they have
hierarchical structure
that is sometimes useful and we care
about this hierarchical structure
but we're not yet at the point where we
have a good understanding
of our toolbox and our
methods that are used for detecting
those hierarchical factors
you can think of examples from social
networks recommendations text analysis
and that they have some hierarchical
structure now i want to convince you
about the fact that
data have hierarchical structure using a
few examples
the one has to do with biology and
it starts in 1831 when charles darwin
went to the galapagos islands to study
the animals that lived there
and what she observed is she observed
several species that shared some
differences had
some similarities and they had some
differences
and she understood that just simply
creating a grouping of those pieces what
we would call nowadays clustering
would not be enough to depict the
detailed
information and relationships that
these species have so darwin
um he thought a little bit about that
and he came up with this
um draft which is a hierarchical tree
that describes different several
relationships among species
for example if we have species a b c d
here
we can see that a is further away from
the rest of the species so it's less
related to them
whereas b and c are closely related and
as a fun fact
out of the 500 pages that darwin had in
his book the origins of species
this is the single figure that appears
so she really thought it was important
and
it was the only one in the book now
biological networks are not the only
ones that contain hierarchies
digital networks also have hierarchies
here is an example of the internet graph
and you can see trees and dendrograms
inside
the final example i would show is from
deep learning
so we now know empirically that deep
neural networks that have several layers
they can detect hierarchical features
for example
you can see here that different layers
can detect maybe
edges other layers can detect corners or
parts of
wheels in the car and the last layer
will detect high level features like
mirrors or wheels and things like that
in my work i tried i tried to develop
a theory of hierarchical clustering that
was mainly my phd faces on
thank you and this is on the realm of
unsupervised learning
and there are of in the realm of deep
learning
i'm trying to understand why depth is
important and i use a variety of tools
like a continuous and discrete
optimization hyperbolic geometry
and also dynamical systems thank you
very much
and i would like also yeah i would like
also to acknowledge all my collaborators
for this
work thank you thank you vagos next up
is fungi
cool you're good whenever you're ready
uh funky i can't hear you
right now all right yeah now it's good
go ahead okay hi i'm fungi
i'm currently a postdoc at harvard and i
got my phd in michigan
my research interest is about
multi-aging systems
here i use the turn agents in its
broadest sense
it can be a group of people an automata
or multiple
neural networks for instance we can
consider a group of people
deliberating and making connected
decisions this problem is known as
social learning or we can design
mechanisms to help a collection of
autonomous child to aggregate their
information
and make a collective predictions this
kind of problem can be known as
federated learning and let me see okay
so tomorrow i'm going to share my work
about how to create
incentivize compatible mechanism to help
multi-agent system to collect
and share their information so i'm going
to use
these three minutes to talk about the
other parts
that is dynamics on material consistency
example of my research includes
decentralized routing in social networks
information cascades and social
learnings
so let me give you one of my examples
a very common a very important problem
in the social network is
why society is divided and
i'm trying to my work is trying to model
these phenomenas
through the lens of multi-agent systems
so uh we models the agents
as notes in some social networks and
they interact with their
neighbors and use some very simple rules
updates their opinions and this kind of
process
is called often called interactive
particle systems
and we want to ask how long does this
kind of random process
take to reach consensus
so if our graph have some certain
structure which is often true in a
social network
we can embed the whole process in a low
dimensional space
for example if we have two communities
then we can embed the process in
in dimensional space and moreover as
the number of agents increase we can
often reduce the problem
the problem cannot be often approximated
by some dynamical systems
and in this case the num
this is a very natural setting because
we've often considered number of regions
very large
and this idea is called amine field
approximations
however there may be some fixed point in
this dynamical systems
and such that the solution of these
mutual approximations is constant
solutions
30 seconds and this is not however the
corresponding random process
should not stop there forever although
the mean field approximation stock
would still stay there forever so uh we
show
a version of uh escaping zero point
results
saying that if you'll notice it if your
noise is large enough then you can
escape that in a very
timely manner thank you awesome thank
you
fungi next up is weiming thung
okay can you hear me yeah perfect okay
uh hello everyone
um from nanjing university
uh my research focuses on sampling
algorithms for gibbs distributions
so the gibbs distribution is widely used
to model joint distributions defined by
local interactions a central research
problem is how to
draw random samples from the gibbs
distribution
this problem is closely related to
approximate counting and
the inference tasks so my research topic
is to design efficient sampling
algorithms for gibbs distributions
by efficient i mean the algorithm should
have certain
good features such as distributed
dynamic
fast and so on so we first studied the
distributed sampling the graphical model
now becomes the distribution network
each vertex is a computer they can
communicate with their neighbors in each
round
and upon termination each of them
output a random value such that their
joint distribution follows the target
gibbs distribution
we propose some algorithms we also
proved the equivalence between
sampling and accounting in distributed
computing model
and we discovered a computational phase
transition phenomena in distributed
sampling
we also studied the dynamic sampling
problem in this problem
we are giving a distribution and a
random sample
then we are giving an update that
modifies the distribution into a new
distribution
the task is to obtain a new sample from
the new distribution with a small
incremental cost
so we give two techniques for this
problem the first one is called
the conditional gibbs technique this
technique turns
the rejection sampling into a dynamic
sampler
and it is also related to the spatial
mixing property of the gibbs
distribution
another technique combines coupling and
the data structure
this technique turns the mcmc method
into a dynamic sampler
the paper will is accepted by itcf and
kung will give the talk tomorrow
another problem is the sampling lover's
local lemma
the algorithmic logos locolima aims to
find the solution
a famous example is the most titled
algorithm
but this task asked us to sample uniform
solution
under a relaxed condition of the local
lemma
we propose a new microchip approach for
this problem
the main advantage of our approach is
that the algorithm is very fast the
running time is close to the
linear so in the future i want to get a
more deeper understanding of these
sampling problems
i plan to study the markov chain theory
sampling lowest local lemma problems in
the new models
and other related topics in the
theoretical computer science
so i will be graduating soon and i'm now
looking for a post operation
that's all thank you awesome thank you
very much fungi oh sorry
wait wait ming next up we have kieran
kumar
thank you
i am a fifth year phd student at
stanford university
and i am jointly advised by professor
moses character and professor
aaron sidford my broad research
interests are in theoretical computer
science more specifically in building
statistical and computational
foundations of data science i'm also
interested in using these tools to
understand problems in natural and
social sciences
i'm currently looking for post-doc
positions
so due to interest of time i'll just
provide a
broad overview of my research
so my primary research so far has been
in understanding
statistical and computational questions
related to
property estimation problem in the
property estimation problem
there is a hidden distribution and you
are given access to this distribution
through iad samples
and the goal is to build estimators
that take minimum number of samples and
estimate a
specific property of this hidden
distribution
so far in the literature people have
come up with property specific
estimators
and in our work we have
through a series of work building upon
some of the previous works we have come
up with an efficient
universal estimator for symmetric
property estimation
by universal estimator i mean one
estimator for all the properties
so to prove such a result we came up
with first
efficient algorithm to compute
something called as an approximate
profile maximum likelihood distribution
it's closely related to permanence
and so this profile maximum likelihood
distribution was
introduced by orlitsky at all back in
2004 but
no efficient algorithm existed for
computing it
and this particular question of
computation of approximate
profile maximum equilibrium distribution
was posed as an open question by acharya
and in the fox sublingual workshop as
well
i have also worked on several other
problems for instance
we have modeled and trail formulation
and shown some interesting properties of
our model
through analysis and simulation we
actually
give a very plausible explanation for
the field observations
of chandrasekhar at all made back in
2019
they showed that ants actually
tend to find a path between the nest and
the food source with minimum number of
nodes
through our model we were able to
provide explanation for such a finding
i've also designed algorithms for
efficient operation of two-sided
matching markets uh
prior to overwork most of the work has
been
in the one-sided matching markets so
these two sided matching markets are
central problem in economics with
applications in labor markets
uh home rentals and many other many
other areas
uh currently i'm working on some kobe
related projects
i'm currently collaborating with la
school district on building models and
understanding the impact of various
testing strategies
uh to safely reopen schools that's it
for me thank you
cool thank you very much um next up is
uh simon
[Music]
is it simon uh yeah yeah correct
okay so this is me so thank you for
being here my name is simon i'm a phd
student in computer science
so my advisors are clear matu and hugo
jambera and i'm doing my phd in france
in paris so my phd is about matching
markets
with random preferences so i'm going to
talk a bit about this later
and i will be probably defending in fall
2021 if everything although
so to describe my research interests so
here is a list of three
ipcs sessions i'm really looking forward
to
so that's there is there was the
matching session uh yesterday
that i really enjoyed because it's
really related to what i'm doing in
my phd so there is a two algorithmic
game theory
uh sessions because i i want to do a
postdoc in a field related to algorithm
3
and also the online and streaming
algorithm session because i worked and
i'm working on some
product like this so let me
give you a quick overview of my research
with an example of results
so that was a paper at ec last year and
so
here is the mall so for this talk i'm
going to take the example of the
job market for products so on the left
you have students on the right you have
products
and a link between a student and a
postdoc means that
the field of the the subject match and
the two could be could be matched
so for the sake of modalization we're
going to say that agents are going to
order the neighbors uniformly at random
and to match students and products
there is two well-known procedures the
student proposing
different acceptance and the postdoc
proposing different acceptance
and one really interesting question
would be to say to ask what is the
probability that
this matching is going to be chosen and
here the
the probability comes from the the
randomness of the preferences of the
agents
not from the procedures because the two
procedures are
actually deterministic and so what was
the result
the result is that actually both
procedures so the
the student proposing and the positive
proposing which yield two different
matching
actually output exactly the same
distribution and in fact
this distribution can be completed and
yeah that's it so uh let me go back to
the first slide
and that's it for me so if you um
yep that's it thank you
awesome thank you very much uh simon um
next up is uh
nathan
hi can you see my screen yep you're
perfect
okay hi uh i'm nitin verma
i'm at the university of fifa and my
research is
uh broadly about algorithms for massive
data sets
uh specifically focusing on the aspects
of efficiency and corruption resilience
uh a little bit about me i'm a postdoc
at the university of fifa
mentored by ellen newman and noga
ranzavi
before coming to haifa i was a phd
student at boston university where my
advisor was sofia raskolnikova
and so when talking about algorithms for
massive data
sets uh one can often model data sets
as functions code words or graphs
and in our study we consider both
classical approximation algorithms and
sublinear term algorithms
as is usual in any study of algorithms
there are several performance metrics to
be considered such as running time
memory efficiency accuracy and
resilience departs and data
and my focus so far has been on running
time and resilience to data faults
and faults and data sets couldn't be of
two kinds errors
or wrong values and erasures or missing
values
and they can occur for various reasons
or one could be issues in data
collection you are conducting a survey
and participants either refuse to answer
certain questions
or give misinformation now when data is
being stored
some of it could be adversarially or
accidentally
deleted or corrupted now a database
administrator
could also decide to hide certain data
points to
protect the privacy of the individuals
concerned
now all of these can be modeled as
errors or erasures
and here is a summary of my work in the
context of sublineation algorithms
the main contribution has been an
initiation
of the study of erasures
in for sublinear term algorithms we have
also studied the relationship between
erasures and errors again in sublimation
algorithms
we have also worked on identifying the
right input parameters
to express the complexity of subliminal
algorithms
and this has resulted in a lot of
follow-up work
for approximation algorithms we have
been interested in investigating
the effects of small perturbations to
the input
on algorithm behavior and i'll be
talking about this
at soda this coming soda i have also
some other work on graph spanners and
some graph theoretic
problems based out of bioinformatics
just a concluding slide
i'm giving two upcoming talks today i'm
going to talk about
erasure resilient sublimination graph
algorithms and at soda i'm going to talk
about
average sensitivity of graph algorithms
thank you thank you for
listening awesome thanks a lot uh nithan
um
and we're on to our final one uh vi
above carway
at uiuc
is my screen visible yep
hi hello everyone i am vaibhav karve
from the department of mathematics at
the university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
my advisor is professor anil hirani and
most of my phd work is revolving around
this
novel graph decision problem that we are
calling graph sat
so as the name suggests this sort of
combines graph theory
and the classical boolean satisfiability
that we all
are used to and we like the idea is that
sat is a hard problem
so maybe instead of solving each
instance of sat we can
group multiple instances of sat into
sort of
clumps and associate an undirected
a single undirected graph with these
groups of instances and solve
it on the graph so this turns it into a
graph decision problem
of course the challenge is that uh graph
sat ends up being
more complicated than sat so we get you
get more structure
but you pay in terms of uh making the
problem even more complicated than it
was to begin with
and we have variants of graph sat
two satisfiability turns into what we
call two graph sets so this uses simple
graph
uh three graphs three sat turns into
three graphs set which uses multi
hyper graphs so these can have edges
between more than two
vertices at a time and so the theory is
complicated which is why it's a
fun problem to work on our main results
have been that two graphs at just like
sad even though it
too sad just like two side even though
it is more complicated
still ends up having a polynomial time
algorithm
three graph set is genuinely more
complicated and it is
uh and we only have an exponential time
algorithm
we are working on trying to uh sort of
find
better and more efficient algorithms for
this problem
all these results so i just wanted to
mention this
all the results themselves and details
can be found in
a paper that i published with my advisor
in discrete applied math called the
complete set of minimal simple graphs
that support
unsatisfiable two cnfs
i can be contacted through
all the details that are present on my
website
i'm in my final year of phd so i'm
currently on the job market for
post talks in both mathematics or in
theory cs
uh most of my interest and my work
uh revolve around computational graph
theory
because i do a lot of programming in
python and my
my style of coming up with results is
usually an experimental style where i'll
i have some conjectures i'll run them
experimentally
sort of on a computer and then try and
prove those results
using pen and paper so i work
around graph algorithms complexity
analysis and this is my
newfound obsession which is formal
mathematics
and interactive theorem proving
especially using theorem provers like
lean
or [ __ ] that you might have heard of
thank you for to gotham for giving me
the opportunity to speak
awesome thank you vibe um yeah and
that's it uh we finished up and we have
uh
three minutes and 45 seconds to spare so
thank you everyone all the
speakers for presenting and uh
cooperating with the
time very restricted time we have and
thank you to all the audience for
coming um all these people are on
one job market or the other so please uh
uh
yeah i hope you found some interesting
candidates and
uh hire them all right so
yeah we're just uh finishing up and
uh the next session i'll direct you to
the other room now
where uh kira is gonna be chairing the
session on algorithmic game theory